a few minutes ago I got back from a walk
that I took from where we live in what's
called West Town to the Third Ward and
all the way down by the hone bridge and
then back again and I do these sorts of
walks pretty frequently you know just to
get some exercise and clear my head and
get some uh you know get some sights in
and all that and as I was walking along
I was thinking about all the times as a
kid that I had come to Milwaukee the
hone bridge is near the Summerfest
grounds and some of my earliest memories
of being here in Milwaukee have to do
with Summerfest which if you don't know
what it is it's the world's largest
Music Festival it's been held here in
Milwaukee for over 50 years and so
that's actually where I'm going to begin
the story but before I do that I'm going
to preface it by saying what I'm going
to talk about here here is sort of
reminiscences of
when I was a kid
um some of the time leading up to my
dad's death you know so while he was
still alive and with us and and doing
things and some of the time after that
so I'm thinking about you know my Early
Childhood all the way through middle
school and then perhaps even into high
school and Milwaukee was at that time
you know a big city smaller of course
than Chicago which is to the South but
still you know the city for us and my
dad worked here in the the very heart of
Milwaukee just blocks from where we live
now he worked for a growing law firm
called touch Ross he was a tax attorney
and so you know he would drive into
Milwaukee every single day and as a
matter of fact during tax season he
would leave so early and come back so
late at night that we wouldn't see him
except on the weekends for you know
weeks and weeks and weeks on end
um but during the summer you know we had
this massive Festival Summerfest that we
would go to and there were always trips
that we would be taking sometimes just
as a family sometimes through Cub Scouts
or some other organization sometimes uh
School field trips and so there were
lots and lots of things that would draw
our attention here in Milwaukee
and the city has changed considerably
since the 1970s and the 1980s that we're
talking about my my childhood
so you know Summerfest itself was really
cool my dad was really into music you
know we had a great record collection
very eclectic Jazz stuff you know
country and folk and Bluegrass and pop
music and rock and roll and there was a
band that he's he just loved called Paul
Revere and the Raiders
um and they were you know rock and roll
band basically and they would actually
if I remember right they'd dress up sort
of in this period costume kind of stuff
and so we would go to Summerfest to see
Paul Revere and the Raiders and that
meant that we would drive all the way
from our place way out in the boonies on
the border of Delafield and Wales all
the way to Milwaukee and find parking
and walk in and Summerfest back then
you know it wasn't like it is today
where the the Summerfest Park is far
more developed than it used to be back
then but it was still pretty pretty good
you know there were these stages that
you would go to and the bands would be
on the stages and there'd be a whole
bunch of different bands playing at
different times and then there was all
sorts of other cool stuff and you know I
went to it on my own or with friends or
you know girlfriends much later on and
then you know it was other sorts of
things that I was paying attention to
but the main thing there would we'd go
and I remember listening to Paul Revere
and the Raiders and sitting on these you
know bench seats with my dad who is
super into it my mom and sister and
sometimes we would go wander off and
play on the rocks that were by Lake
Michigan
and you know they tell us don't go too
close to the lake you know uh and then
you know every once in a while they'd
look over to make sure that we weren't
hurting ourselves or falling out of rock
or you know wandering off too far and
then we'd come back again and as a
family we would you know walk around the
grounds and listen to other bands
whoever else was playing that my parents
were into and there were sometimes like
you know things for kids there as well
there was a playground where you know
they would take us to and there was uh
an entire Midway with games that you
could play and you know we'd beg our
parents to let us try to shoot guns at
the the balloons or you know do the
water stuff or the ring toss and try to
win some some things stuffed animals
coasters all the knick-knacky crap that
they they sell at these things and then
there were rides so you know my Dad
loved going on roller coasters and
things that spun and so I would go on
with him my mom wasn't quite so in into
that and my sister was younger so they
would often do things like you know go
on those little car rides where you just
go around in a circle and
you know we'd we'd spend all day there
and then we would drive back home I
think I probably would sleep in the car
as did my sister because it would be
dark by the time we were heading home so
Summerfest was a really big thing that
we would do here in Milwaukee sometimes
we would go to the State Fair in
Milwaukee as well but a lot of what we
would do was more oriented towards
we could call it cultural enrichment
stuff so
one of my favorite places to go and and
I did this with my family quite often
but we also did this through school was
the Milwaukee Public Museum which is
going to be closing down pretty soon and
and you know moving to a new location
where they're building a whole new
building and there's lots and lots of
drama right now about which exhibits are
going to get saved and you know the
museum was was really interesting
not all of the exhibits that exist in
the present museum were there back then
and some of them you know sort of
developed and appeared
as our childhoods progress so there'd be
like a new thing you know and I remember
you know some of the features that I
really loved the European Village which
is this essentially dioramas with all
these houses
with European you know folk art and
furniture and people in costumes all
these are all you know mannequins of
course and so you know you'd go from
house to house to house to house and
it'd be like you know here's the Greek
house and here's the Belgian house and
here's the Ukrainian house and here's
the Spanish house and some some were big
and some were small and they were all
pretty cool and then next to that was
streets of Old Milwaukee where you could
go wander around through this you know
thing that was supposed to represent
Milwaukee around like 1910 or 1920
and it was uh that was a pretty cool
exhibit as well and there were things
about the uh you know Menominee Indians
and French Canadians and the exploration
and and uh trading posts and all of that
in this area the French Canadian you
know Milwaukee was actually founded by a
couple who was French Canadian and
Menominee and
um you know then there were all of these
you go upstairs there are all these
really cool
dioramas some of which were just animals
some of which were various peoples all
sort of ethnographic and it was a way to
learn about people in all sorts of other
parts of the world and to learn about
the continent that we live on and what
the biomes are like and there was also
another thing that if you're from
Milwaukee you know about this there's a
an amazing diorama of Lakota Indians
hunting on horseback Buffalo
you know spearing them and stuff like
that and there's actually a rattlesnake
and there's a little button and you've
got to go and find the button amongst
the Rocks then you touch it and it
rattles and stuff like that so the
Milwaukee Public Museum was a big deal
sometimes we would also go to the art
museum as well and that wasn't such
a fun time for most of the kids but I
really loved it there are
works of art there that I have been
going back to and looking at again and
again since I was you know
before I was a teenager and later on
when I actually lived not far from the
museum I used to go there almost weekly
and just spend a little time hanging out
and checking out the the artworks but
another thing that we would get as we
would come into Milwaukee
particularly with school field trips
were we would go to the theaters or the
performance halls and so there were lots
of
um
you know classical music performances
that we would get to go to of course you
know Peter and the Wolf is like the
thing for kids but you know they would
and they wouldn't impose on us any super
long program but we did get exposed to
some good classical music from time to
time coming in from Wales Elementary or
university Lake School I I don't
remember our high school doing anything
like that I guess they weren't into that
sort of thing but we also went to a lot
of plays
and that was really quite cool to see
plays and musicals and you know for all
of these field trips there was always a
permission slip that you had to fill out
and your parents had to sign and they
would have to uh pay a certain amount of
money I guess it was contributing to the
bus or something like that because we'd
almost always be taking a bus or several
buses and going out to wherever we were
we were going to be for the day and then
you'd have to pack a lunch you know a
bag lunch literally in a brown paper bag
um
I don't really remember anybody
purchasing launch at any of these places
and oftentimes we'd have to eat on the
bus uh you know so your lunch would like
you'd have your label on it and it would
sit by your seat and uh or maybe you'd
take it along with you I don't I don't
quite remember exactly how we did it but
this is part of the whole production
right so there's the getting and the
whole day the whole school day would be
consumed with this sort of stuff because
we lived so far out that it was at least
an hour's Drive especially in a bus to
get from where we were starting to where
we ended up in Milwaukee and then
there's all the rigmarole of like making
sure that all the kids are where they're
supposed to be and doing head counts and
all that so the entire day would be
consumed in that and then there of
course there'd be chaperones as well not
just teachers but parents who came along
for the trip
and I think I recall my mom chaperoning
once or twice but she didn't do it very
often and my dad was always too busy to
to do that sort of thing and so anyway
there are all these great things that we
would do here in the downtown of
Milwaukee and it's fun as an adult as
somebody who you know has left their
childhood behind you know 40 years ago
right I'm I'm 52 right now so a 12 year
old me in middle school that that's
four decades ago
I walked past the same places that we
used to have to drive into or bus into
and things have changed a lot in the
downtown but some of the things haven't
changed that much you know we have a
beautiful new Symphony Hall but the old
one I remember that and I remember going
to the Performing Arts Center and I
remember going to the Milwaukee
Repertory Theater and I remember going
to all of these sorts of you know
museums and other other performance
places as well and it was quite cool to
do that I will mention one other thing
too
when I was in middle school and then in
high school a friend of mine
his parents were actually
College professors and I don't remember
exactly what they taught but they would
sometimes invite me to go to University
Wisconsin Milwaukee for lectures and I
remember like for example going to a
lecture on elasticity as a physical
property and getting rubber bands and
those being props and stuff like that so
that was that was kind of cool as well
and I'll I'll close by bringing up
something that really has changed about
Milwaukee so I mentioned we would have
to take the buses in and we would be on
Interstate 94 because that was the main
trunk into
you know the downtown of Milwaukee it
actually 94 goes all over the place uh
you can take it further west and get to
Madison and go all the way you know into
Minnesota and Beyond there you can take
it south and and go into Chicago and
then eventually it connects up with um
you know 80 for a while and then heads
up through uh through Michigan
so we would go from Wales or Delafield
or Heartland or wherever we were all the
way out to Milwaukee on 94. and as you
got closer and closer to the downtown
a smell would hit you
a yeasty smell a very strong smell and
then you knew oh we're getting close
right what was that well that was the
yeast smell from all of the breweries
that were still active in Milwaukee
Milwaukee was a massive Brewing town as
a matter of fact there's all sorts of
old breweries that were you know vacant
for a while and got turned into uh you
know incubators for businesses or into
restaurants or a lot of them got turned
into housing Lofts Condominiums things
like that and you don't smell that smell
anymore as you're driving around but it
was so pungent and some people really
didn't like it I loved it I for me it
was sort of a reminder of where we were
and what we were doing it was like a
sign that in another you know a few
miles or so we'd be stopping and and
getting to do something really cool here
in the downtown of Milwaukee getting
exposed to a world that was only for
occasions something that we could only
enjoy you know once or if we're lucky
twice a semester while we were in school
these field trips were a big big deal
you know and so it was really quite cool
to be you know chugging along and around
you know 35th Street or so you'd start
getting hit with that Brewery smell and
now you knew that you were you were here
you'd arrived right and it would
wouldn't be long before we were going to
get off the bus and then of course it
would be the same going back out it
didn't smell like that in the downtown
itself
but once you got past you know once you
got into the 20s to the 30s because uh
Milwaukee streets are numbered and they
go
um higher up as you go from east to west
right beginning with the river actually
uh so you know that was kind of a cool
feature so I just thought I would tell
you about that I'm really fortunate in
that uh we live here in the downtown we
can enjoy these things all the time I
can walk around and see all these cool
theaters as a matter of fact I used to
walk the dogs when they were still alive
past all of these things when we'd take
our long walks so I'll leave off there
and I thought I'd just share a little
bit of that
not a little bit but quite a few of
those childhood memories with all of you
about getting to go downtown here in
Milwaukee and how cool it was and how
much fun we would have even though we
didn't get to do it very often it was uh
quite a treat when we did